nate diaz come get the interview boy i'm
waiting on you all y'all stockton's
finest come on bro hey come get it with
a real one bruh reel to recognize real
come on and come get it have you reached
out to the ideas outside of right now
i think i talked to
a publisher i talked to her about
getting to it but i think i even dm'd
him just on some [ __ ] like man whoop
that whipped that boy ass yeah just on
some regular show i couldn't help myself
is that like uh who who are like three
or four people who
you know
you would just love to interview whether
it's a nate diaz or just somebody like
that that you're just a fan of it you're
like man i would just name diaz i'd like
to get him up in there kevin gates i'd
like to get him up in there because i
always know he got some wild [ __ ] to say
super wild andrew tate yeah come run it
okay me and you we gotta run one up
youtube interview might get pulled down
it might get pulled but you know what i
know how to navigate the conversation so
i think that we might be able to do good
and just do the numbers even though i
know it's going to be peaking the
[ __ ] feeling it's going to be oozing
you might have to go to romania for that
but you know hey man it might be worth
it it might be [ __ ] worth it it would
be worth it it would you know i'm making
the move bro you got to make whatever a
wherever hey wherever it takes me me and
my spanish guitar what were you thinking
like when you
when you saw him get banned off the
internet like what were your thoughts on
that
that's just you know
you and i both know okay when it comes
to radio when it comes to social content
when it comes to any kind of content
there's always a cap of what they feel
you can say so you don't disturb society
right that's pretty much what it is and
they they capped him that's what i look
at it as he he tried to see how deep the
rabbit hole goes and
it started hitting rock
yeah that makes any sense like no
freaking you're not mad at him because
i'll say this like you know you want to
be open hey be open do your thing
brother i ain't got nothing against that
but that's what they're going to do to
you they're going to try to cap you man
there's too many people that run that
[ __ ] on the other side that's just
you're outnumbered right it's just a
slippery slope when you start banning
people because it's like okay so now
that it's a precedent that people can
just be deleted off the internet it's
like just like that and like obviously
if you've eaten like that yeah first of
all he's eating crazy but also like i
would say like 90 of what andrew tate
was saying
was probably like
i wouldn't say rat i mean like i could
understand like yeah yeah he's just his
delivery might be you know but whatever
i get it he's you know i would say the
other 10 might be a little problematic
if like 12 year old kids are watching it
on tick tock but at that same time it's
no different than when you and i were
growing up and [ __ ] eminem came out
talking about raping his mom we didn't
go [ __ ] rape our mom you know what
i'm trying like right right right like
at the end of the day because i think
that's really probably the biggest
concern was like well his main audience
are kids and we don't want kids growing
up being yeah they don't stay yeah they
don't but but it's like if you're doing
your job as parents because i feel like
there's and i'm not gonna speak on what
but i feel like there's a lot of other
things that they let just naturally
organically be be some encouragement
and they don't mind that and i don't
want to speak on things that i want to
get tons of stuff whether it's music
whether it's interesting there's a lot
of stuff that they say hey let them have
a choice so like come on man like open
if you're going to open it up open it up
yeah i just think no if you're going to
open up the [ __ ] door don't crack it
right open the door right right don't
try to find things that okay this this
passes
oh okay and this passes no you don't you
stand over here to the side of the line
we'll talk to you in a second
all right this one passes y'all three go
over to this side like come on man it's
like this wild and crazy [ __ ]
that's being marketing the kids is okay
it's okay but this [ __ ]
y'all gotta it's oh it might just
disturb these kids it might give them
the
a false sense of something they don't
need to be believing in or
looking at but like come on man who's
controlling this
like who's controlling these narratives
like who's making up these shitty ass
[ __ ] rules of what they feel like
society
it's really all the tech companies man
and it's like crazy because like you
said it's like controls the tech
companies
right oh you don't talk about it mark
zuckerberg i don't [ __ ] know mark
zuckerberg goddamn yeah what's the other
guy uh who runs google right i think
it's an asian guy [ __ ] you know where
i'm going with it it ain't just him
look at him bro joe byron
no presidente joe sleepy joe i don't
[ __ ] know
i i don't know who man
like i said i just know that like
if you're gonna
long story short and keep it for what it
is if you're gonna crack the door
open it up yeah like to me to me it's a
slippery slope when you make a bunch of
this [ __ ] okay whatever this is your
favorite words that's a slippery slope
you've used that a few times now so if
all this is okay right yeah but then
this little like
that isn't even necessarily maybe as
outrageous as some of the stuff over
here yeah yeah they but as you know i
like i said
there's this rules people make up man
are you worried about that like are you
worried like um
you know like when you when you when you
when you do certain content like yeah
you know uh
does it ever cross your mind when you
see something like what happens to
andrew tate like oh maybe i gotta tone
it down a little maybe i gotta i mean i
feel like mine's more of a figure of
speech i'm actually talking to the
person that i'm saying it about versus
doing just a video sitting there
speaking this to everybody putting it
out in the world this is a real time of
how i feel and a real interaction with
somebody and i feel like people if
you're
if you're smart you know how to separate
the two right you know what i'm saying
so that's how i really feel about it